all right this is the swearing-in
of clark county commissioner marilyn
kirkpatrick
all right commissioner kirkpatrick
please raise your right hand
and please repeat after me
i state your name i marilyn k
kirkpatrick do you solemnly swear do you
solemnly swear
that i will support that i will support
protect and defend protect and defend
the constitution and government
the constitution and government of the
united states
of the united states and the
constitution and government
and the constitution and government of
the state of nevada
of the state of nevada against all
enemies against all enemies
whether domestic or foreign whether
domestic or foreign
and that i will bear true faith and that
i will bear true faith
allegiance and loyalty to the same
allegiance and loyalty to the same
any ordinance any ordinance resolution
resolution or law or law of any state
not withstanding
of any state not withstanding and that i
will
well and faithfully and that i will well
and faithfully perform all of the duties
perform all the duties of the office of
of the office of clark county
commissioner
clark county commissioner for the board
of county commissioners
for the board of county commissioners on
which i'm about to enter
on which i'm about to enter so help me
god so help me god
thank you
all right if we could now have clark
county commissioner michael naft
please come up to the podium be sworn
commissioner naf please raise your right
hand
you can put your bible on your your left
hand
there you go all right please repeat
after me
i state your name i am michael nathan
naft
do you solemnly swear do solemnly swear
that i will support that i will support
protect and defend
protect and defend the constitution and
government the constitution and
government
of the united states of the united
states and the constitution and
government
and the constitution and government of
the state of nevada
of the state of nevada against all
enemies
against all enemies whether domestic or
foreign whether domestic or foreign
and that i will bear true faith and that
i will bear true faith
allegiance and loyalty allegiance and
loyalty to the same
to the same any ordinance any ordinance
resolution or law resolution or law
of any state notwithstanding of any
state notwithstanding
and that i will well and faithfully and
that i will well and faithfully
perform all of the duties perform all of
the duties
of the office of of the office of clark
county commissioner clark county
commissioner for the board of county
commissioners for the board of county
commissioners
on which i am about to enter on which i
am about to enter
so help me god so help me god
thank you thank you
and i'd like to invite up onto the
podium
clark county commissioner william
mccurdy ii
who will be yeah who will be sworn in
by our newly elected north las vegas
justice court
judge belinda t harris
i need you to raise your right hand
put your left hand on that bible are you
ready
we're ready okay i state your name
i william o'neill mckerty ii do solemnly
swear
do solemnly swear that i will support
that i will support
protect protect and defend the
constitution
and defend the constitution and the
government and the government of the
united states
of the united states and the
constitution and the constitution and
the government
and the government of the state of
nevada of the state of nevada
against all enemies against all enemies
whether domestic
whether domestic or foreign or foreign
and that i will bear true
faith and that i will bear true faith
allegiance allegiance
and loyalty to the same and loyalty to
the same
any ordinance any ordinance resolution
resolution or
law of any state or a law of any state
notwithstanding
not withstanding and that i will and
that i will
and faithfully and faithfully perform
perform
all the duties all the duties of the
office of the office
of the clark county commissioner of the
clark county commissioner
of the board of the county commissioners
of the board of county commissioners
on which i am about to enter on which i
am about to enter so help
me god so help me god thank you
congratulations
next i would like to have justice silver
come back
for the swearing in of ross miller
[Applause]
i am so honored to be here to swear in
ross miller who began his career as a
deputy district attorney in the clark
county district attorney's office with
me
as one of his senior deputies that he
worked under
and just watching his career
becoming an amazing deputy district
attorney and and what he's done
since then i'm very proud and honored to
be able to
swear you in today ross miller county
commissioner
thank you so please at this time
please repeat after me and raise your
right hand
i state your name i ross miller
do you solemnly swear do you solemnly
swear that i will support
that i will support protect and defend
protect and defend
the constitution and government the
constitution and government
of the united states of the united
states and
the constitution and government and the
constitution and government
of the state of nevada of the state of
nevada against
all enemies against all enemies whether
foreign
or domestic whether foreign or domestic
and that
i will bear true faith and that i will
bear true faith
allegiance and loyalty allegiance and
loyalty
to the same to the same any ordinance
any ordinance
resolution or law resolution or law
of any state notwithstanding of any
state not withstanding and that i will
well and faithfully and that i will well
and faithfully
perform all of the duties perform all
the duties
of clark county commissioner of clark
county commissioner
for the board of county commissioners
for the board of county commissioners
on which i am about to enter on which
i'm about to answer
so help me god so help me god
congratulations commissioner ross miller
thank you silva
thank you ladies and gentlemen for
attending the swearing-in
ceremony i believe that the
commissioners
are getting ready to go right to work
by nine o'clock so thank you all for
attending
and have a great and safe day thank you